so when you went to apply for a mortgage
that was just when rates were going up
yeah my interest rate actually increased
by three percent so like everyone
especially across the education system
and teachers I've had to look at all of
my um like finances and just look at
where I can fix in rates so that I know
what my budget is going to be every
month
the cost of a living crisis is making
even those who saw themselves as
comfortably off well a little less
comfortable a poll for Sky News shows
that the economic pain is increasing
especially for those paying a mortgage
Lucy who works at the Tutoring company
is among them I main thing for me was
actually just looking at I actually
never really done it before just look at
all your direct debits really go into
sort of a deep dive into your own
finances and just see where you can make
you know make changes 32 of people say
their mortgage or rent payments have
increased over the last three months for
those paying mortgages rather than
renting have felt the most pain 36 say
their mortgage costs have increased and
they think they know who's to blame for
that people believe the conservative
party's economic policies and government
and the decisions made by the former
prime minister Liz trust are the two
most important factors slightly ahead of
the state of the global economy and
Trust may be gone but people have doubts
about her replacement Rishi sunak 42
percent of people trust labor leader Kia
stammer to reduce the cost of living
only 34 percent trust the prime minister
to do the same the data shows that more
than 90 percent of us are still
concerned about the cost of live living
crisis those attitudes are translating
into action one in four people say that
they've been using credit cards to buy
essential items like food the same
proportions say they've sold some of
their possessions to try and make ends
meet the most vulnerable are undoubtedly
facing the most pressure but almost
everyone is feeling the squeeze in some
way some people are clearly having to
take quite drastic steps but real worry
is looking at those those people who are
having to do things like skip meals fall
behind in payments
um even for you know a relatively small
number
um are but higher amongst young people
out say having to move in with friends
or families all of that even before we
get to the recession predicted by
economists Tom Cheshire Sky News
bracknell